So what if there were not only an internet of information,
what if there were an internet of value?
Some kind of vast, global, distributed ledger
running on millions of computers and available to everybody,
and where every kind of asset, from money to music,
could be stored, moved, transacted, exchanged and managed,
all without powerful intermediaries.
What if there were a native medium for value?
Well, in 2008, the financial industry crashed,
and perhaps propitiously, an anonymous person or persons
named Satoshi Nakamoto created a paper
where he developed a protocol for a digital cash that
used an underlying cryptocurrency called Bitcoin.
And this cryptocurrency enabled people to establish trust
and do transactions without a third party.
And the seemingly simple act set off
a spark that's ignited the world, that
has everyone excited or terrified or otherwise
interested in many places.
Now don't be confused about Bitcoin.
Bitcoin is an asset.
It goes up and down.
And that should be of interest to you if you're a speculator.
More broadly, it's a cryptocurrency.
It's not a fiat currency controlled by a nation's state.
And that's of greater interest.
But the real pony here is the underlying technology.
It's called blockchain.
So for the first time now in human history,
people everywhere can trust each other and transact,
peer to peer.
And trust is established not by some big institution,
but by collaboration, by cryptography,
and by some clever code.
And because trust is native to the technology,
I call this the trust protocol.
Now you're probably wondering, well,
how does this thing work?
Fair enough.
Assets, digital assets like money to music and everything
in between, are not stored in a central place.
But they're distributed across a global ledger
using the highest level of cryptography.
And when a transaction is conducted,
it's posted globally across millions and millions
of computers.
And out there around the world is a group
of people called miners.
These are not young people.
They're Bitcoin miners.
And they have massive computing power at their fingertips,
10 to 100 times bigger than all of Google worldwide.
And these miners do a lot of work.
And every 10 minutes, kind of like the heartbeat
of a network, a block gets created
that has all the transactions from the previous 10 minutes.
And then the miners get to work trying
to solve some tough problems.
And they compete.
And the first miner to find out the truth
and to validate the block is rewarded in digital currency,
in the case of the Bitcoin blockchain with Bitcoin.
And then, this is the key part, that block
is linked to the previous block and the previous block
to create a chain of blocks.
And everyone is time stamped, kind of like
with a digital wax seal.
So if I wanted to go in and hack a block
and say, pay you and you with the same money,
I'd have to hack that block, plus all the preceding
blocks, the entire history of commerce on that blockchain,
not just on one computer, but across millions of computers,
simultaneously, all using the highest levels of encryption
in the light of the most powerful computing
resource in the world that's watching me, tough to do.
And this is infinitely more secure than the computer
systems that we have today.
Blockchain, that's how it works.